it's kind of funny in the 80s during the
Cold War the Russians were like the bad
guys to put in movies in these movie
started coming out that showed it may be
the United States and Russia maybe they
can become friends again I feel like
this kind of what this movie is is some
weird full circle thing where movies are
starting to reflect 80s Cold War movies
again it's weird
[Music]
hunter-killer so hunter killers a movie
I've been looking forward to for quite
some time easily one of my most
anticipated movies of 2018 I saw the
trailer for this thing and then I saw
the trailer a lot it's like every week I
went to the movie theater I saw a
trailer for Hunter Killer in case you
couldn't sense the sarcasm none of what
I just said is true at all like what is
this movie where'd it come from this out
of nowhere doesn't matter so stars
Gerard Butler he plays the commander of
the submarine Commons in the movie plays
a two-star general Gary Oldman he's a
guy is like a pentagon guy government
guy yells all the time there'll be some
spoilers in here I mean I don't consider
them spoilers anything that seems like a
spoiler that I say it shows in the first
half of the movie but I don't know
you've been warned it doesn't matter my
god is hunter killer and judging by the
poster alright try to guess what this
movies about I'm about to Zell there's
been a coup in Russia the Russian
president has been overthrown so these
American special forces guys got to go
in there and they got a rescue the
Russian president yeah and there's a
submarine I mean they got to bringing
this up as transport but really the subs
just a transport it all starts out with
this fishy his submarine disappeared and
Russian waters kind of thing but it
quickly develops into something deeper
than that
I think deepers wrong word thicker than
that that's right you ask any pornstar
thicker does not mean deeper it looks
like two different episodes or two
hour-long movies that were just stitched
together to become one movie it just
ends up feeling a bit too convoluted
it's a bit of a mess and I get the
movies not trying to be Macbeth in fact
when I was watching this movie and as
I'm talking about this movie I'm trying
to keep in mind what this movie was
really trying to be though I referenced
the 80s earlier really this movie is
trying to be a cheesy 90s action movie
because that's kind of Gerard Butler's
thing now he's like hey I'll be the guy
who's in action movies that are trying
to be cheesy action movies of the past
here today bring back some of that
nonsensical fun but in making a movie
that's trying to feel like a fun cheesy
90s action movie sometimes you just make
a movie that feels like a cheesy 90s
action movie not quite as funny as you
wanted it to be this movie doesn't have
cool stuff but anything that's cool in
the movie you have to look past logic or
physics like this submarine is banking
corners it probably shouldn't be able to
bank doing moves it probably shouldn't
be able to do this thing probably should
have been destroyed I don't know four
times maybe five and really it always
bothers me when a solution a logical
solution presents itself and it's just
overlooked because no one there has
logic we got to create tension for the
sake of tension otherwise there'll be no
movie like this coup happens there's
video of it and by video I mean it's
video of these three guys the
president's men being execute
the Russian presidents like yes you
bastard all on video that the Americans
have no like is there any way we can
prove this as a coup does the whole
thing is the Russian military guy who's
the leader of this coup he's keeping the
Russian president hostage but it's all
secret by the way the Russian government
the troops all think oh hey his orders
are coming from the president he doesn't
know that this guy's actually running
the show now you have video evidence a
big damning piece of evidence that could
crumble at all if anyone knew oh my god
how do we prove it since we have it on
video man if a picture's worth a
thousand words what's that video word
leaked it to Russian authorities leaked
it to the UN leaked put it on Twitter i
should'a circulate pretty fast due to
lose his power because he has a small
little band of people compared to the
entirety of the government that are
loyal to the president but now let's do
the long-winded got to go in there with
the troops get the president out get
into the sub and then the chase sequence
and why not also Russians can't shoot
for [ __ ] or rather Russian ammunition
can't hit anyone for [ __ ] like their
scenes bullets are just being sprite and
they're running like oh man bullets
going right by them no one's getting
hits like what is everyone fortune from
Metal Gear Solid 2 or some [ __ ] you guys
would be perfect to join the Empire
because you are stormtroopers guys in
the end I appreciated what this movie
was going for what it tried to do what
it was trying to be cheesy 90s action
movies starring Gerard Butler we've seen
it before it's worked sometimes but in
the end it comes across as $0.99 Jack
Ryan enter title here it's totally $0.99
Jack Ryan would've been a perfect movie
just released straight to Netflix or
something paying full ticket price for
the movie did probably not it had some
enjoyment in it I just can't tell you to
go spend your money on it cuz I'm
probably not gonna remember this movie
in t-minus one day ya already forgot
alright so hunter-killer have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]